c'était il ya 25 ans en écosse une
avancée scientifique qui avait frappé
l'imaginaire la naissance de dolly le
premier mammifère issus du clonage d'une
cellule adulte
le montréalais laura smet a contribué à
cet exploit il ne s'attendait toutefois
pas à un si grand intérêt du public
avait pas vu vraiment comme la réaction
commun les nuages même façon si si fort
de l'île a été cloné grâce à la
technique de transfert nucléaire de
cellules somatiques
les chercheurs ont prélevé une cellule
de la brebis en ont extrait le noyau et
le matériel génétique puis ont implanté
ce noyau dans un ovule non fécondé
quelques mois plus tard une nouvelle
brebis presque identique à la première
rapidement les implications de cette
découverte fascine le public est une
question s'impose pourrait-on clown est
un être humain en utilisant le même
procédé c'est clair que c'est possible
biologique peu de temps après la
naissance de dolly les ralliés affirmé
avoir réussi par aman à la réussite du
premier coup si je peux dire puisque son
il s'agissait finalement d'un canular et
rien n'indique qu'un être humain était
et clown et depuis
d'autres mammifères en revanche selon tt
vaches chiens cochons souvent à des fins
commerciales à saint-hyacinthe par
exemple le célèbre taureau starbucks
avait été clonés pour cette raison mais
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas tant le clonage
qui intéresse les scientifiques que la
recherche en génétique cellules souches
technologique crise peur la science a
beaucoup évolué depuis de lits à méguet
un centre de recherche en a fait sa
spécialité
quels principes l'éthique quand lamar
ahmad d'avoir la docteure n'a peu
s'intéressent surtout aux questions
éthiques entourant la génétique et
discussions éthiques ont vraiment
commencé avec la naissance de louise
brown avec la fécondation in vitro en
1976 louise brown s'était des gamètes
ces deux paramètres imaginer toutes
sortes possible d tiéné d éveil ou
étaient des balises en 2018 si ben ali
sont remises en question lorsque e jam
coûts et annonce avoir créé les premiers
bébés génétiquement modifiés le
chercheur chinois cherchait à immuniser
des jumelles contre le vih devant le
tollé international
il finit en prison ça chaque demande que
tam d'orly parce que en principe pas y
arriver on parle toujours pour prévenir
éviter pensait d'avancé tout seul tout
coup beig le lendemain dans jonah lomu
vendus en eau cette arrivée est fait ici
pour la docteure nos peurs il faut un
consensus international pour éviter de
tels dérapages ce n'est plus un
phénomène d'un pays ou de nationalité
aux d'une science depuis 2004 il est
illégal de clown est un être humain au
canada
[Musique]
il aura fallu dix ans de débats pour
arriver à cette loi mais depuis la
réglementation n'a pas évolué
il faudra probablement attendre la
prochaine grande découverte qui
captivera l'imaginaire collectif
et si à ce média radio canada montréal